das ist irgendwie durchtrainierte
geworden
ach du heilige mutter gottes
ganz schön hart vor einiger zeit habe
ich schon mal auf eine folge reagiert
von hilf mir jung pleite verzweifelt war
super und in meiner reaktion auf diese
folge habe ich einfach aus spaß
gefragter rtl2 kann die man ganz
auftritt bei rtl 2 hat dann unter meinem
video kommentiert bewerbung ist
angenommen worüber ich dann jetzt an in
meinem video berichtet habe und in
meinem gestrigen video habe ich euch
auch gefragt hier um eine abstimmung und
können sagen auf welche der beiden
folgen ich morgen reagieren sollen bei
dieser umfrage kam raus dass sich auch
die folge verliebt in den chef reagieren
soll deswegen heute meine damen und
herren luca reagiert auf hilf mir
stalker alarm verliebt in den charts
also der läuft eine frau in den
blumenladen rein und was machst du jene
eltern haben mich nun rausgeschmissen
zwar endgültig mein aufrichtiges beileid
meine eltern mich rausschmeißen würden
würde ich auch als allererstes und im
blumenladen laufen aber ich habe doch
nur dich tante garden tante gabi ist
dass das tier wollte jetzt irgendwie
blumen für die eltern kaufen
das ist eigentlich ein plastik pflanze
von ikea nur darauf gewartet dass ich 18
bin und den nicht auf der tasche liegen
ok
warten heißt dieser blaue dings dass
jetzt eine therapeutin kommt so kann es
tatsächlich kommen stefan bartels
rechtsanwalt mal schauen was er zu sagen
hat ab dem 18 lebensjahr sind die eltern
nicht mehr zur betreuung ihrer kinder
verpflichtet das heißt konkret sie
müssen ihnen auch kein dach mehr über
dem kopf bieten wurde zuhause
rausgeschmissen warte ich seit kurzem
rechtsanwalt einen ihr wenn man 18 jetzt
kann man die schmerzen werden
du hast doch noch die wohnung
ich vermiete es normalerweise jeden
monat für 200 euro
ich gebe dir geld sobald ich geld habe
die hoch und dann schnell zu arbeiten
hat kann sogar wie kannst du mir noch 20
euro lag
wenn ich hier irgendwelche personen sag
ich mal beleidige versteht bitte dass es
nicht gegen die richtigen personen geht
sondern nur gegen diese gespielte rolle
aber scheint so als seien die eltern von
der ali nicht heftige vor schweiz die
erst mal raus
die dann nicht mehr geld wird ja nicht
mal 20 euro dabei ich konnte dass meine
eltern mich rausgeschmissen haben ja ich
weiß schon scheiße so ohne geld du hast
es erfasst
darf ich das nochmal in slow motion was
sie gesagt hat du hast das leben
verstanden
da muss ich wirklich sagen ohne geld
leben die schleife wird wenn ich erst
eine tobias zusammen denn dann habe ich
überhaupt keine geldsorgen
typisch typisch frau nichts gegen alle
frauen nicht dass wir jetzt gegen die
nachgesagt wird ich wäre geschlechter
feindlich aber da wird auch in dieser
folge wirklich komplett diese standard
klischee sachen werden immer
aufgegriffen sei es jetzt wenn da
irgendwelche ausländer rumlaufen oder
wenn jetzt hier die mädels pleite ist
dann sucht sie sich einfach einen
reichen freund in die schon sehr
bedenklich wie hier rollen dargestellt
werden ich glaube du hast eine
kleinigkeit vergessen steffi unsere
ausbilderin die sind verheiratet
einlegen will sich den chef klären
eigentlich verheiratet ist absoluter
wahnsinn mal wieder also jetzt kommt ihr
irgendwie so eine andere frau seien auch
sie mit handschuhen es die denn das ok
durchtrainierte worden
ach du heilige mutter gottes
das ist ja an kriegsmaterial nicht mehr
zu überbieten studio davon eine ecke
nach dem da nicht auch und das ist gut
zwei mal liebevoll hergerichteten
bestimmt sondern wir mal es war einmal
die woche geht dahin
ich glaube jetzt kommt die steffi an
seine verlobte zu schätzen die
bestellungen
das ist doch echt ekelhaft ich das
anzuschauen und jetzt holt sich an linie
wahrscheinlich bei ihrer komischen
geldsorgen so richtig scholze war
freunde aus doch er wird mir auf jeden
fall zu füßen liegen dann damit
ich werde mich einfach verändern haaren
das modulare neue ist immer klasse dubai
arbeitet in einem friseursalon hast aber
alles so viel geld nennt sie kann ich
bin 50 euro ich bin genauso viel wie du
und ich kann es mir auch nicht alles so
kacke aber es ist wirklich eine
notsituation also das ist eine
notsituation wird gerade bei den eltern
rausgeschmissen hat keine wohnung hat
sich von tante gardine besenkammer
besorgt vom tanz egal wie noch 20 euro
geliehen und jetzt muss sie ja auch noch
die 50 euro von der ich weiß schon
scheiße so unendlich von dilettanten
musik sicherheit auch noch fünf jahre
lang fw ein notfall leute die ihn
braucht neue haare um den tobias aus
seiner ehre zu holen was sag ich mir ja
aber 30 euro
aber den will ich auch wieder sofort
zurück haben denen will ich auch wieder
sofort zurück haben den 30 euro scheins
und auch in friseur laden gehen der
macht doch schon immer um 15 uhr zu und
dort den schlüssel oder ich habe wenn
ihr uns erwischen ich kann mir noch
nicht bringen nennt sie die affichen uns
schon nehmen also schauspielerisch wenn
ich da meine note vergeben darf das
skala von 0 bis 17
es hat für mich - 4000 außerdem habe ich
doch gar keinen bock auf berufsschule
haben jetzt einfach ein minirock orten
ist es viel wichtiger
da gebe ich dir definitiv rechts
heiligen braucht dringend eine zündende
idee um geld aufzutreiben
nein nein
rechtsanwalt der jetzt sagt dass das
diebstahl als beim griff in die kasse
kann die 18 jährige nicht widerstehen
wenn man etwas klaut dann ist das
diebstahl und das ist illegal
doch damit nicht genug
nein um den verdacht von sich zu lenken
steckt aline der angestellten ihrer
tante einen teil des geklauten geldes
dreist zu fliehen
wenn ich deine mutter wäre würde ich
dich auch ausschweifen alimi ist
glücklich
okay war rtl 2
ja echt wahnsinn ich weiß ja wer das
gerade gehört habt ich werde auch gleich
weiter laufen lassen dann hätte das
bestimmt
der moderator der das sonst immer
moderiert hat und gesagt hat was jetzt
gerade abgeht in welcher szene die sich
gerade befinden
er wurde einfach tonhöhen tiefer gemacht
sie wollten eigentlich eine neue stimme
haben hat wahrscheinlich kein geld und
haben dann einfach den bisherigen
moderator genommen seine stimme einfach
vertieft die geklauten 400 euro ihrer
tante hat die 18-jährige komplett in ein
neues outfit investiert sie ist sich
sicher mit einem sexy styling muss ich
ihr schiff das hört man doch voll
was denken sich denn da die leute in der
in der redaktion nach ihr
das ist die brille von dem rechtsanwalt
ja liebe es hilft mir team wir bräuchten
dann noch eine neue stimme für diese
folge um bisschen abwechslung rein zu
bringen
ich schau mal wie viel budget noch 22
eur 20 tontechniker kannst nicht einfach
den jetzigen moderator ein bisschen
tiefer machen aber war schade und die
linie 10 tore beeindrucken kann berlins
umstyling läuft anders als geplant
geklaut
diesen sorgen besen treue extensions
kann ich halt eben noch nicht so ihr
könnt mit der eilige die nächste boden
wischen auf aktiv- tobias treten dann
kannst du mir noch mal geld leihen
pauli
du hast gerade 400 euro aus der schweiz
blumen kasse geklaut es war das letzte
was ich dir gegeben und wir am nächsten
habt ihr das gehört
der kater hat
einfach die moderator stimme sekunde zu
früh gepackt haben am nächsten tag eher
der 249 cutter braucht ihr könnt gerne
mich einstellen
[Musik]
online eileen
jetzt entdeckt die in der carrer von
gabi noch meine handtasche klaut wieder
was raus oder was
die cloud die kreditkarte
ich krieg' ich echt die voll krise mit
dir ne berlin hat alles scheint von dem
katalin hat alles auf eine karte gesetzt
und zwar auf die ihre tante
ok der job ist neuer look interessiert
chefin stefanie nicht im gegensatz zu
ihrer masse um für später
die machen der ihn eh nichts als im
fitnessstudio lauer tallinn ihrem chef
also erstmal wieder doppelter moderator
fehler und jetzt wartet aline im gym auf
ihren ski-fans trainieren denn berlin
allerdings nicht
sie will nur mit aller macht tobias
rumkriegen
das ist auch immer meine intention im
gym die da eigentlich nur hin um tobias
rumzukriegen ich trainiere jetzt auch
hier nicht dann ist unbedingt nötig
hätte aber ich habe ich auch angemeldet
ich habe mir das echt nicht mehr lange
geben
ganz schön hart hey tobias ich hab dich
beim training vermisst ach du scheiße
jetzt setzt sich danach zudem tobias und
tobias säuft sich ein bier da rein das
ist eingeschmuggelt ja das habe ich
jetzt echt mal gebraucht warum die
straße mit steffi ich meine du bist doch
wirklich eigentlich so eine treue seele
das auch wüssten
[Musik]
hast du kacke
oh mein gott er ist verheiratet
ich habe die komplette glaube die
menschheit verloren leute ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich will mir diese scheiße nicht
weiter anschauen wenn ich da bock drauf
habt ich habe euch die ganze folge und
in der beschreibung verlinkt schaut sie
euch gern an ii verliert dabei hat zwei
dreitausend gehirnzellen wenn euch meine
wii action hier auf diese folge von
hilfe gefallen hat das gerne mal einen
like darauf welche folge solcher als
nächstes reagieren
oder soll es einfach sein lassen
scheiße
[Musik]